the loud house is jam-packed with jokes
that make both kids and adults laugh out
loud but sometimes children don't have
the slightest cue why their parents are
stifling a grin
well that's probably because this
cartoon is loaded with jokes that aren't
meant for kids watch until the end to
find out which loud house moment was a
little too daring well well well look at
you mr. date khakis but pizza for some
strange reason kids think that butts are
hilarious and chances are if you're
giggling right now you're no older than
12 years old in season 3 episode 25
there was a moments that made kids laugh
while adults raise their eyebrows in
disbelief in the episode titled missed
connections we see the twins Lola and
Lana take their but obsession to a whole
new level
the twins answer the front door to find
the pizza delivery woman she hands them
a pizza that's shaped in a heart which
was sent to Lorie by Bobby
the twins are obviously confused by the
heart but their confusion turns to
adoration who in Londa turns the heart
upside down and reveals that it's
actually a but I think it's supposed to
be a but then to our great dismay Lana
and Lola share a look before devouring
the pizza but like total animals if
that's not inappropriate we don't know
what is
creeper alert season 3 of the loud house
is no stranger when it comes to adult
jokes so we're not surprised that one
slipped by fans in the episode titled B
Stella my heart the 21st episode of
season 3 starts by introducing a new and
adorable character Stella is the new
girl at school and Lincoln and his
friends are crushing on her hard hey
guys during one of their gawking
sessions Lincoln's friends each take the
time to say something they like about
Stella we find out that she can speak
three languages and I hear she speaks
three languages has a contagious laugh
it's so contagious and is easy on the
eyes then out of nowhere rusty tells the
boys that he loves the way Stella's hair
smells I like the way her hair smells
this is super creepy considering he
would have needed to get super close to
her to take a whiff hey Ikes
watch your back Stella rusty doesn't
know what boundaries are heated toilet
seats once again were about to be
reminded of Lana's
with the butts but this time she has a
new partner in crime and it's her frog
hops in season 3 episode 35 we find out
that mr. loud has bought an old
restaurant and plans on fixing it up he
asks his kiss for help and they split up
to take on different tasks this episode
is titled cooked and it reminds us of
just how special the loud children
really are
while Lana is talking to her dad hops
flushes the toilet and walks out of the
washroom with a super red butt he looks
like a baboon and frog hybrid Lana goes
on to say that hops was just testing out
the heated toilet seats but we know full
well that the restaurant doesn't have
this luxurious bathroom accessory so
what in the world happened to the frog's
butt mountain of bills who doesn't love
a good old musical episode in season 3
episode 31 we see the loud family burst
into song on different accounts the
episode really loud music follows Luna
as she tries to come up with an original
song the rock star stumbles upon her
parents tallying up some bills in the
kitchen the couple starts to sing a duet
about having money problems
but we'll be fine
however this tends to go right over the
younger audiences heads after all they
don't know about the struggles of paying
bills just yet we've always wondered how
the Louds could afford to have such a
big family but after hearing their duets
we now know that they can't in fact
they've got a mountain of bills and debt
on the brain
24/7 relatable episode 35 of the loud
house is riddled with moments that
aren't meant for children so we're going
to be taking a second look at the
episode titled cooked after fixing up
his restaurants mr. loud is now on the
hunt for a new employee he uses his
children as judges because he values
their opinions problem is his
contestants aren't exactly qualified
when a cute teenager applies for the job
mr. loud quickly finds out that he's the
least responsible person ever all the
kids vote against him except Laurie who
gives him two thumbs up when her
siblings give her side eye she says but
I find him relatable hmm alright there
Laurie we're sure that's all it is burn
out there's nothing like going out for
nachos with friends however you can't
always trust that the first food worker
is going to be in a good mood we have
the number three combo with fries for
everyone in your party adults know a
thing or two about burnouts which is why
this scene made them laugh out loud cry
Lincoln and Lynne are grabbing a bite to
eat when their plans start going awry
the employee at the nacho Hut's is
obviously going through a lot he's
beating the cheese machine with a stick
and losing his marbles at the same time
before long the worker rips his shirt
off and starts yelling at the top of his
lungs although this teen has kids
laughing it had grown up shaking their
heads for very different reasons the
meet song in season 3 episode 34 we get
to see a side of mr. loud and Luanne
that's just a tad bit annoying the
father and daughter duo can't help but
make puns at the grocery store and it's
driving Lola crazy this episode which is
titled home of the fav takes Luanne and
mr. Lotz humor to a whole new level they
sing a song about fiends while at the
cash
and even sound out fart noises Lola
turns back to the customers and tells
them to be happy that they didn't catch
the song at the meat counter at this
point an exasperated customer reveals
that he did hear it so what was so bad
about the meat song that stopped viewers
from hearing it themselves hmm we think
we know but if you don't catch our drift
this joke will remain a mystery and tell
you're much older Luna and Sam Sunnah is
one of the best ships in the loud house
fans cherish every moments between Luna
and Sam for obvious reasons however
there was one scene that was borderline
inappropriate this segment showcases Sam
and Luna baking something in the kitchen
Sam is full of flour which causes Luna
to laugh so Sam tacos Luna and rubs the
flour all over her face the girls are
laughing so hard they fall to the floor
and before we know it their laughter
stops and the girls share a frisky look
while this might have seemed like no big
deal to most people grown-ups know
exactly what the cartoon was insinuating
before you go let us know who your
favorite loud house character is in the
comments below give this video a big
thumbs up if you love the loud house and
while you're at it make sure to hit that
subscribe button thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]